Hello and welcome to this video. In this, we're going to carry on with the exercise
and we are going to create a secondary branch to our behavior tree.
And so I'll jump back into the engine. So I'm going to go back into our behavior tree.
We're going to create a secondary path across here, and I'm going to call this Follow Player.
I'm going to drag off. I'm going to select another sequence and I will rename this to Follow Player.
Okay, now we can put the tasks in in a second, but what we want to do is we want to have a way
of making sure that we can choose which one of these paths we're going to move between.
And what we're going to use in this case is if the player has been detected.
We're going to use a service in order to figure this out.
So I'm going to come up here and I'm going to do a drop down on service
and I'm going to select BT Service Blueprint Base. Okay, and we talked about service before.
I'm going to call this S is Player Close. And that's going to create another class,
which is very similar to the tasks that we've been working on before.
It's got eight overridable functions. And for this we're going to do everything on
Receive Tick AI. And this is good because it's going to run on every tick
and it's also going to allow us access to the controlled MPC Pawn.
Okay, so we have something that looks a little bit like us.
And what I'm going to do is the first thing I want to do is get the player character.
So I'm going to type in Get Player Pawn. And to start off with, to prevent any errors,
I'm just going to check to see if this is a valid Pawn. So I'll type in and go
is valid and select the question mark so that we've got a branch here.
And I'll plug that directly in. Now we've got the controlled Pawn and I want to see the
distance between these two and check to see if it's below a certain value.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag off of the controlled Pawn
and I'm going to go Get Actor Location. Now give me a vector of where the actor is in the world.
I'm going to do the same for the Get Player Pawn. So Get Actor Location.
I want to know the distance between these two. So if I drag off and type in
distance, you'll see that we have a function to measure the distance between two vectors.
And that will return the value as a float. So I'm now going to push down B to bring up a branch
and left click. And I want to check to see if this float is below a certain value.
So I'm going to do less there. And for this I'm going to use 150.
And I'll plug this into the branch. So only if the player character is under 150 centimeters
from the MPC will this do whatever we attach to true. And for this we want to get some
information out of this. So again we're going to need to use a variable. And I'm going to
call this variable player. I'm going to make an instance editable by hitting this little I.
And I want this to be a blackboard key selector. I'll drag this in, drag off and go
set blackboard value as object this time. And I'll plug that into true.
And I will get the player, get player pawn. And we can be pretty sure this is valid
seeing as we've checked just a little bit back. So that should be fine. Now with the service
you don't need the end execute because this is going to run regardless. And there's no sort
of fail condition on this. It will just run. So I'm going to go compile and save.
Now let's use this within our behavior tree. You jump back to our behavior tree. I've got my
followed player. I'm going to drag off and I'm just going to add in a change color task.
And that's so that we can see if this is working or not. I'm going to change that to red.
So I've got the red one. And make sure the else there is a one as well. So we've got a
red color. Now I want to run this service. I'm going to add it to the selector here.
So I'm going to right-hand click, come down to add service and I'm going to select is player
close. Now that's going to run. You can see every 0.4 or 0.6 seconds. I can change the
interval here, but I'm quite happy with it running that frequently. Now there is one thing
I want to change though. At the moment, by default, the player variable is going to be
saved to the self actor blackboard key. We really want it to be saved to the player
because that's what we're going to be using to determine how we move through the behavior tree.
Now there's one more thing that we need to add to get this to work, and that is on the
wander around. If you right-hand click, come down, we want to add a decorator.
And if you remember, the decorators are what we use as filters. And this is what we can use to
stop the behavior tree going down this path. So I'm going to come up and I'm going to use
the blackboard. Now I'll select the blackboard and I'm going to change the
key query. I'm going to change to is not set and select player. So what this is saying
is only do this if the player is not set. Right, so let's try this out. I'm going to push save,
and then we're going to jump back into the level. Here we go. We can see we've got all
the different characters, and if I wander up to one, follow him around for a little bit,
you should see that he turns red. So he's detected us and he is now going to turn red.
There you go. You can see that one's turning red as well. Now this isn't ideal,
and that's because even though they are detecting the player when we get close to them,
it's waiting until the entire task is finished before it turns red. That's not what we want.
We want them to instantaneously detect the player. So how do we do this? I'm going to jump back
into the baby tree and select the wander about task as you select the blackboard decorator.
Now at the top, we've got a flow control set and we've got observer aborts. Now we have
no abort set at this point, so I'm going to do a drop down. I'm just going to change this
to south and you can see that's going to show that this entire area would be aborted.
So I'm going to save, jump in, and now try it out again. So as soon as I walk up to a character,
as soon as it runs that service, it will abort the activity it's doing at that point.
Okay, now that's looking good. Let's make them do something else rather than just stand
around. And that's quite straightforward because we've already written a lot of the code that we
need for this. So we've changed the color. Let's come in here and change the speed next.
And we're going to change the speed to, let's set it to 400. So they're now running after
the character. And the final instruction we're going to use move to again. What we're going
to do in this one is rather than move to the self actor, we're going to move to the player.
So let's save that. And so your entire chart should look a bit like this.
And I'm now going to run. And as we detect the players, you can now see
all the characters are going to chase the player that we've got.
So there you go. We can collect up the NPCs as we move forward.
And with that, that brings us to the end of our behavior tree exercise. Next up,
we're going to be looking at state trees and how they vary from the behavior trees.